radiophyra belonged to a general group
of ciliates called aztomes or as tomatid
ciliates as tomatid ciliates are diverse
but they are unified by one shared
feature or rather they are unified by
their lack of one shared feature a mouth
and they do not need a mouth because
they have something even better they
have worms as Toma did ciliates do
parasitize animals other than worms some
live inside mollusks others inside
leeches or even in amphibians but they
are most commonly associated with the
guts of annelid worms as Doma did
ciliates are found in hosts from all
sorts of environments some live in soil
some live in ponds some even live in
ocean waters and scientists are using
the general tools available now to try
and piece together how host and
endosymbion have shaped each other